car dans son clip tout de suite
maintenant on passe car dans 100 foot
et on va parler d'abord de camille
combal sur qui veut gagner des millions
ça y est c'est officiel bonne ou
mauvaise idée on aura nicolas pernikoff
et kevin vatant qui vont venir nous
rejoindre également
ça a été annoncé par le parisien hier
après-midi grosse grosse info donc il va
remplacer jean pierre foucault vous le
savez mon ami jean-pierre vous avez un
petit magnéto récap regarde c'est une
nouvelle à laquelle on ne s'attendait
pas camille combal va prendre la tête du
jeu mythique qui veut gagner des
millions
après avoir interrompu les missions en
2016 tf1 a décidé de relancer le jeu qui
avait fait les belles heures de la
chaîne durant 16 ans et c'est jean
pierre foucault lui même qui a soufflé
le nom de celui qui le voyaient comme
son successeur
j'ai proposé camille combal à tf1 car je
me reconnais un peu en lui la chaîne il
pensait aussi c'est sans nostalgie avec
une certaine tendresse
on m'a passé plusieurs fois le relais au
cours de ma carrière comme guy lux avec
intervilles
c'est mon âme qui a parlé camille de son
côté n'aura pas beaucoup d'efforts à
faire pour se mettre dans les souliers
de jean-pierre ça fait déjà de
nombreuses années qu'ils s'entraînent
dans l'ombre et jean pierre foucault en
a je fais bonsoir
alors les français vous regarde qu'est
ce que vous en pensez et c'est lors
d'une émission spéciale que jean pierre
foucault passera officiellement le
relais à camille qui s'est lui aussi
exprimé sur ce transfert
les gens ont envie de retrouver ce jeu
car c'est une référence à la télévision
c'est impossible de refuser un cadeau
pareil je l'alignerai à ma façon
naturellement alors camille c'est votre
[Musique]
il combat la nôtre ami camille qui
remplace jean pierre foucault est ce que
c'est une bonne ou une mauvaise idée
kevin vatant de morandini.com voilà ce
qu'ont du blog de jean-marc voilà qu'on
embrasse et nicolas pernikoff ancien
patron des divertissements passe
télévision il nous rejoint merci d'être
là vous avez donné votre avis alors des
gens on va écouter un petit peu vous
bonne idée jean michel mr bones ibrahima
chaussée le money des parce que dans ce
jeu là il ya beaucoup de sang attend
tous les candidats sont en train de
réfléchir à la bonne réponse devrait du
coup il ya des espaces on peut on peut
parler on peut dire des connaissances il
veut un peu déconné et je trouve que
j'adore g j'adorais jean-pierre mais si
quelqu'un doit le remplacer tous que
camille combal
il a ce naturel s'est réparti pour
mettre un peu de faire un coup de folie
danseuse dans cette émission
alors daniel vous trouve que c'est une
mauvaise idée vous oui et pas par
rapport à à camille combal mais moi je
pense vraiment que ce jeu est incarné
par jean-pierre foucault complètement
alors ligne itunes c'est une mauvaise
idée de toute façon de faire ses
émissions sans jean pierre foucault ou
alors c'est un jeu je dois dire je
pourrais je veux dire que c'est la
classe incarnée janquin flower il se
sent va tranquillement il a sa vie
ailleurs aussi il laisse sa place à un
jeune file et il est parfait de bout en
bout mais je trouve dommage et c'est un
cadeau empoisonné moi je pense pour
camille combal on le lâche un petit peu
trop jeune il n'a pas il y avait des
silences mais justement il y avait une
complicité on a une complicité avec jean
pierre foucault qu'on n'a pas encore
pour l'instant en tout cas que le grand
public n'a pas encore avec camille
combal que steam on avait dit par
exemple que julien lepers à processeur
parti voilà qu'ils rêvent que ça aurait
fait chuter d'une audience pas du tout
j'adore julien lepers mais le concept
est tellement fort qu avec samuel
etienne ça fonctionne très très bien
alors je prends tu veux gagner des
millions c'est qu'elle avait arrêté
parce que les audiences avaient été très
mauvais oui oui mais je dire ça c'est
pas parce que justement on est un
programme est incarnée par quelqu'un
qu'on change de présentateur est clair
moi justement alors ç'a marché hyper
bien que jean-pierre après le concept
c'est un petit peu usé et visuellement
voté pour il va donc voilà peut-être
pour relancer peut-être vrai mais jean
pierre séré que moi j'en pire pour moi
ça va vous faire baisser mon frère je
lai mais c'est vrai que je vois là c'est
vrai que j'aime avoir du mal à voir
quelqu'un d'autre mais c'est c'est
camille donc voilà j'ai peut-être je
vais je fais bien sûr regardé nicolas
pernikoff qui souvent pensé moi je pense
que c'est une émission qui est ultra
mécanisée à savoir que tout à l'heure je
voudrais faudra enlever le micro des
drass merci jean michel disais tout à
l'heure c'était qu'on allait pouvoir
avoir un peu de fun sur qui veut gagner
des millions je pense que c'est le
dernier endroit où il faut faire du fun
c'est ultra mécanisée c'est un jeu est
elle vraie
un mature j ai je pense que ce qui est
important c'est justement de conserver
l'âme de qui veut gagner des millions
alors effectivement ça marche très bien
vu qu'est ce qui marche pas samaras a
conservé l'avantagé pas de la faute de
jean pierre des corps mais bon c'est pas
de la faute de jean pierre foucault qui
vous embrasse puisque j'ai eu au
téléphone
bah je t'embrasse fortement sur ce sujet
la deuxième chose c'est attention c'est
un jeu important c'est un blockbuster
mais il faut en avoir des blockbusters
aujourd'hui qu'est ce que vous avez
comme jeu aujourd'hui à part qui veut
gagner des millions d'autres posteurs et
la femme
rien n'a pas les mêmes maillots moi je
moi je vais bien le maillot ya un mois
des drones d'actes membres les boîtes
après je pense qu'il ya des gens comme
benjamin ya peu de gens qui seront
capables de faire des jeux aujourd'hui
tenir une mécanique de jeu
c'est une mécanique de jeu avec une
vraie dramaturgie et ça va pas être
évident pour famille kevin effectivement
ce que dit nicolas il faut avoir une
certaine rigueur dans ce genre de
programme donc ça j'ai un petit doute en
revanche cani son côté friendly peut
être tout à fait efficace parce que par
rapport aux invités qui a dans
l'émission quand il ya du gad elmaleh
xetra il faut que justement quelqu'un
qui joue le jeu avec avec ses invités
donc pourquoi pas mais j'ai quand même
un doute par rapport à la rigueur comme
tu dis allah alors oui benjamin non à ce
que croit ces mauvaises idées pour mars
et le deuxième programme qui prend en
main qui est un problème qui est un peu
usé et un peu anciens et une danse avec
les stars maintenant il ya les médias
les millions dans le cas des millions
franchement foucault il incarné de façon
magistrale c'est très compliqué de le
remplacer et ce jeu en particulier et
contrôler ce que vous dites c'est il
faut pas du tout faire de blagues et
faire des bébés dette c'est tout
l'inversé
c'est ces tensions et non il ya beaucoup
d'argent en jeu il faut surtout pas d je
dis pas je dis pas qu'il ne fera pas
bien je dis que i les gens qui aiment le
programme à mon avis ils vont être
surpris
voilà ce que le rythme élevé alors
prononcé imaginer camille combal dans
qui veut gagner des millions
regardez on a fait un match pour garder
qu'est-ce qu'on est content d'être à mes
goûts concevoir à tous sera vite pour
trouver enfin qui sont dans les
startings de moi toute la période de la
6ème vous connaissez parfaitement les
missions exactement stressé ou pas ne
pensais pas que ça serait aussi
stressant ça va très bien se passer ce
qu'un jury particulièrement que vous
redoutez on a enlevé bien garni par un
c'est sur un tango argentin vous avez
lancé cette saison on a même une star
internationale avec nous cette année je
pense que c'est lui j'aurai l'occasion
de voir à quel point elle parle bien
français
heureusement parce que l'anglais mois
explique ce compliqué qui qui va être le
partenaire thirith huit navires us et
jeanne mas très bonne fin de soirée à
tous
salut tout le monde est-ce que ça va
arriver mais c'est arrivé premier
semestre 2010 9 une première sera
enregistrée par jean pierre foucault qui
va ensuite passé le relais à camille et
où palier de fun va y avoir dans la
nouvelle version que des stars donc ça
va s'y prêter plus en plus
merci c'est vrai qu'avant il y avait que
des ringards vous restez avec nous les
séries on va passer au deuxième sujet du
jour c'est michel cymes qui sera en
colère contre eux gilles verdez 20
contre nous et en particulier contre
gilles verdez on vous explique tout en
vidéo il veut la tête de gilles verdez
est ce que vous êtes choqués ou pas
choquer vous nous dites c'est parti
regarde entre michel cymes et gilles
verdez ça n'a jamais été le grand amour
depuis plusieurs années le médecin le
plus célèbre de france a du mal à
supporter les remarques du chroniqueur
de tpm paix sur son travail et ses
programmes
mais alors que les choses semblaient
s'être calmées depuis quelques mois
michel cymes en remet une couche cette
semaine et cette fois ci il va loin
selon le blog de jean-marc morandini il
aurait demandé à la direction de ses
huit la tête de gilles verdez en
menaçant de ne plus participer à aucune
émission du groupe canal
la raison de ce coup de gueule les vives
critiques de gilles envers scène sortira
pas dit si le nouveau talk show du
docteur animateur lançait la semaine
dernière sur france 2 4 avec sa
pitoyable pour trois raisons d'abord
c'est vulgaire très gênant parce qu'il
est auto centré dans ses interviews il
se fout des invités ont fait qu'ils
posent des questions à lui même et ça
moi j'en ai marre
et puis surtout j'ai un immense malaise
par rapport à la médecine
m'enfin ce monsieur se prétend médecin
il l'est d'ailleurs sans doute et il
utilise sa fonction de médecin pour
faire un show pour pervertir ça
vision des remarques qui ne passe pas
pour michel cymes qui a adressé une
lettre à cyril en lui demandant
d'arrêter de critiquer son émission
avant que son avocat n'écrivent donc à
ces huit pour demander la tête de gilles
alors comprenez vous les menaces de
michel cymes alors choqué ou pas de
choquer comprenez vous les menaces 2006
m et moi je veux pas de problèmes
[Rires]
très énervé et qui est très choquée je
crois que c'est le signe que oui parce
que je ne comprends pas que l'on puisse
c'est le principe de l'émission on va
l'être touche pas à mon boss de
critiquer les programmes ou bien de les
encenser de donner son avis premièrement
deuxièmement michel cymes n'est pas
systématiquement attaqués ou
personnellement j'adore c'est un très
bon copain
j'aime beaucoup et troisième point moi
ce qui me sens que je crains c'est
vouloir faire taire la liberté
d'expression ça ça m'inquiète dans leur
secteur et gère des cipan problème ou
leurs cercles à la liberté d'expression
tant qu'on respecte les textes ou qu'on
respecte la loi tant qu'on est dans les
cordes
pourquoi faire la terre la liberté
d'expression ne doit donner son avis
positif ou négatif
alors kévin sûr j'ai une question pour
gilles est ce qu'il vous a appelé lui
d'intervenir via son avocat parce que là
c'est même pas une chasse mais ce qu est
internet alors qu'est-ce qui s'est placé
devant le gardien mais qu'est ce qui
vous a passé un coup de fil absolument
pas jamais au téléphone jamais vu jamais
parlé alors ça dure bien longtemps cette
histoire il baird et michel cymes
puisque c'est en mars 2007 dans
l'émission médias le mag sur france 5
le médecin avait déjà parlé vous
apparemment ils vous êtes l'invité
touche pas à mon poste bas j'y suis même
allé j'y suis allé deux fois trois fois
dans au début à partir du moment où
quelqu'un de l'équipe insultes c'est
gilles verdez on va le site est pour
vous parce que ça vous agace de
continuer de laisser je suis devenu son
attaché de presse à chaque fois que
j'avais quelque part on n'a jamais
entendu parler de ce type autant que
depuis qu'ils m'insultent heures il
n'insulte pas que moi moi je veux dire
les huit fait partie du groupe canal et
je trouve qu y avoir ce genre de chroni
sniper qui assassinent les gens
permanence sur une chaîne de ce très
beau groupe qui est canal je trouve ça
pas digne
sa taille est une île de la chana oui je
trouve pas ça digne du groupe canal
alors moi je veux dire à une petite info
c'est que michel cymès a même appelé je
crois les dirigeants du groupe canal
pour leur demander la tête de gilles
verdez et je vous dis
voilà moi si gilles verdez s'en va je
partirai bien entendu avec lui parce
qu'il est hors de question que cela
gilles verdez c'est son travail
donc bien sûr lady les dirigeants de
canal n'ont pas écouté qu'il viendrait
nous pas écouter michel cymes mais
gilles vous aurez toujours la liberté de
dire ce que vous voulez vous avez des
programmes que vous aimez vous avez des
preuves que vous aimez blanc et michel
il ya plein de gens qui t'aiment ici il
ya plein de gens qui me déprogramment
donc il faut arrêter oui daniel g
rechercher quelque chose et c'est quand
même un peu pathologique chez michel
cymes parce que il y avait le
l'excellent son excellent documentaire
hippocrate aux enfers pardon qui avait
été critiquée par une journaliste de
télérama ce qui est tout à fait normale
elle n'avait pas aimé elle l'avait dit
et il l'avait limite insulté il avait
fait une page de réponse le lendemain
donc je pense malheureusement il ne
supporte pas la critique que ce soit de
gilles verdez ou d'une critique de
télérama et du monde je crois les deux y
avait avait pas trop aimé avait émis des
réserves
donc ça c'est quand même un peu
pathologique et c'est embêtant parce que
quand on est animateur préféré des
français il faut supporter une petite
critique
mathieu après 2001 du talent le problème
c'est que ça y est ils présentent tous
les stigmates de la grosse tête
c'est à dire que maintenant c'est vrai
mais c'est ça c'est à dire ne pas
supporter d'être critiqué est menacée
que sade que ça donc que sa non présence
soit d'aucune menace mais pardon mais je
pense que tout le groupe canal se fout
totalement à merville ne viennent pas
sur une de ses émissions
donc ils pensent que ça nourrit la
baisse des prévisions du groupe pour
dire voilà j'en bois des lettres ça va
mal se passer faut qu'il redescende un
petit peu avec le groupe canal il faut
virer gilles verdez michel aulas
j'appelle pas france télévisions pour
faire virer que telle ou telle personne
donc arrête d'appeler appelle moi si tu
veux on en parlera à tous les deux ah
non je ne conseille pas de gilet bleu
après peu touche il devrait venir plus
ça devrait venir pour s'expliquer mais
en plus elle appela qu'il aime ici mais
alors parce qu'il ya un mois je fais
passer pour un con parce qu'il ya moi je
les deux le des fois mais à l'infini cm
selon mercer c'est vrai que je suis
spécialiste du sport tas c'est pour
rencontrer la belle allée pour défendre
hier je le défends parce que il y avait
un clash avec jean michel cohen qui
travaillent sur ces vite jeudi c'est lui
qui a raison
il a la classe j'arrive tout à l'heure
on guette a vu ce qu'il a faim il a
envoyé un avocat pour un port pour taper
sur ses invités pour taper l'ait laissé
ses huit tranquille
tout le monde va taper sur ces vip et
tout le monde va mettre ses 8 ans
d'honneur là je vous le dis il a perdu
une roue le docteur moi je vais lui
donner son symptôme
tu as perdu une roue michel cymes
reprend corps
[Applaudissements]
les cuisses il est touché et tout ça
parce qu'il ya je suis notre omni en
petits tas d un gain net d'ici j'ai j'en
ai rien à [ __ ] si j'étais déjà dit si
tu veux voilà une partie sert il vient
d'y ce que tu penses
la jeune dit michel bouvard à l'aller
face aux dégâts alors n'est pas choqué
dit les rats moi je suis pas choqué par
ce parce ping pong de critiques parce
qu'en fait c'est juste de bonne guerre
c'est la télé qui les emmenait et moi
mais gilles verdez de lampes à la mise
en demeure de noix pas la tête à ça mais
on prend pas d'avocat oui oui oui non ça
c'est vraiment tout ça veut dire que ça
c'est un fait voilà ensuite si mais ça
peut passer de personnages préférés à
bête à abattre c'est vrai qu'on parle
beaucoup de lui
il est assez critique et peut-être parce
qu'il ya de la jalousie moi
personnellement ces programmes qui fait
pour l'instant je les aime bien donc ce
qui serait bientôt si le compte y est
qu'ils viennent ici et que vous ayez une
confrontation sympathiques comme tu
avais fait avec la sympathique benhaim
avec la glace alors vos ping pong c'est
bon de bonne guerre on va la vie de
nicolas pernikoff vous étiez son patron
à france télé bah écoutez je ne le
reconnais pas avec noir de leur action
c'est maintenant tous et pas du tout
dans son adn on va très bien avec une
sorte de chaise si tu veux venir
tu es le bienvenu mais oui mais déjà
qu'il a peints de vous répondre au
téléphone à la rive a jamais venir ici
ouais c'est vrai il répond pas au
téléphone certains mais pour l'instant
il me répond pas michel sache que si tu
- numéro après numéro non non je crois
qu'il va bien désirable merci on va pas
ce troisième sujet du jour êtes vous
choqué par les nouvelles révélations sur
johnny c'est un croyant encore à wayne
on est encore des révélations sur les
siens puisque sur c'est vrai on garde
encore un truc qui rallie vous qui vient
d'arriver
non mais attendez deux minutes lemercier
alors la france entière apprenait le 2
février dernier que johnny hallyday
avait complètement rayé david et laura
de son héritage s'en est suivie une
lutte médiatique entre les deux camps
d'un côté laetitia de laura et david
mais cette affaire pourrait prendre un
nouveau tournant aujourd'hui avec les
dernières révélations dévoilées dans un
nouveau livre encore ils se sont tant
aimés
c'est un livre qui fait énormément
parler regardez où vous a résumé ses
grosses révélations nord on en parle
après c'est un s'arrête pas mon soprin
regarde c'est un truc de foule
[Musique]
alors que l'album posthume de johnny
continue sa course folle avec déjà neuf
cent mille exemplaires vendus cette
bonne nouvelle pour le clan laëtitia est
contrastée par des révélations autour du
patrimoine du chanteur qui ressurgissent
dans un livre la journaliste léna lutaud
révèle que le patrimoine immobilier du
chanteur déclaré officiellement ne
serait pas complet en plus de la villa
jade estimé à 35 millions d'euros deux
autres magnifique villa se trouvant sur
l'île de st barth appartiendrait au
chanteur mais elles auraient été cachées
par laeticia et ses avocats un livre
dans lequel on apprend également que les
pensions entre laetitia et laura et
david d'attrait d'un événement survenu
en 2009 le chanteur à l'époque malades
avaient pour projet d'adopter un
troisième enfant avec sa compagne
mais les premiers enfants de johnny se
serait fermement opposé à cette idée une
intervention que laëtitia n'aurait
jamais digéré et les révélations sur le
roi du rock ne s'arrête pas là après son
patrimoine caché ce sont ses souvenirs
cachés que l'ami du chanteur régime
décide de révéler dans un livre elle
raconte que contrairement à ce qu'il
disait partout johnny avait en fait
rencontrer son idole elvis presley une
rencontre qui aurait lieu dans une boîte
de nuit parisienne
mais ceux qui n'auraient prêté aucune
attention à l'interprète d'allumer le
feu laissée par cette rencontre ratée je
n'y aurais demandé à régine de ne jamais
révéler cette anecdote alors êtes vous
choqué par les nouvelles révélations sur
johnny les droits la révélation sur
johnny alors il ya d'abord les biens
immobiliers alors il y en a plein qui
sont choqués va choquer ici alors donc
dans ce livre est donc il n'y ait
dévoilé plein de choses je vous dit
notamment que laura et david auraient
récemment découvert qu'en plus d'être en
partie rayé du testament de johnny en
plus de tout ça des biens immobiliers
auraient été cachées par laetitia
laetitia posséderait trois biens
immobiliers sur l'île de saint barth
ce qui est fou c'est que déjà hier dans
dans 7 à vous ils ont même des dix sites
et les maisons c'est ça qui est fou
parce qu'elles sont en vente voilà c'est
vrai il ya une vie d'aller bien de
laëtitia saint barth la villa jade voilà
à 35 millions d'euros la villa sylvestre
4,4 millions d'euros et la ville à joy
12,8 millions d'euros servir 52 millions
d'euros de biens à saint barth
alors vous vous êtes choqué alors j'ai
plein d'autres révélations à vous allez
voir et vous allez savoir dans un
instant qu'elle est vraiment
l'incroyable raisons de la brouille
entre les deux clans qui a été enfin
rêver vous êtes choqués et bernard
auquel vous connaissez bien le dossier
oui je alors est ce que c'est vrai pour
les chr estimé c'est vraiment surestimé
ça franchement je joue depuis la visite
et le nonce à sa porte
on était comme ça où tu as tu vis à vis
pour moi ça vaut tous les villages à
2,35 c'était les magnifiques celle-là
bon travail et on voit des photos ou
tout comme ça que c'est un tracé pour
faire parce qu'en fait la sauvegarde et
on a le prix en balade dirhams et
environ 12 fois ses 12 millions il met
ses pas 35 meur mais sont alloués aussi
donc on peut très bien les visites et
facilement sur le net vous tapez vous
les avez il ya là villaggio
effectivement qu'on a découvert alors
tout cela c'est un tiers appartient à
johnny et laeticia un autre tiers à jean
claude darmon l'homme d'affaires
meilleure à celle de johnny à canberra
notre tiers à une sci assez mystérieuse
et effectivement ça pas été déclarées au
fisc français
il ya une autre villa peut dire que la
ville a joy donc le seul que ton
viennent découvrir et à est la réplique
presque exact de jade en tout petit elle
est dessous d'ailleurs et l'autre ville
a effectivement ça c'est une vraie
découverte
on ne le savait pas et moi non plus je
ne savais pas d'ailleurs d'accord et
donc que vous en invité dans cette
guerre savoir lundi la secrète ya
montiel qui vient casse la ville à bord
de regarder le vis-à-vis alors vous
n'avez pas choquer et jean-michel je
suis pas choqué déjà bernard est très
gentiment fait dire que on ne savait pas
c'est parce que tu ne savais pas que
personne ne le savait je pense que des
villes là comme ça à savoir c'est pas
une en exige tout cas ce ton si tu peux
maintenant maintenant je pense que le
fisc est très au courant de ce genre ne
vivra pas non mais qu'est ce qu'on sait
et autres biens la même réplique à tout
le monde
déjà pas choquer on n'est jamais sûrs je
suis pas choqué par la vérité en tout
cas donc si ça sort bien d'autres choses
qui sont sortis d'eux dans le point
laetitia avait déclaré que suite à
l'annoncé du concert de johnny en 2016
david aurait mis six mois pour venir
voir son père tandis qu'il a fallu
quatre mois alors à mai selon l'auteur
du livre la vérité serait tout autre
selon leur version ils n'ont été mis au
courant que très tardivement de la
maladie de leur père johnny ne leur en a
jamais parlé c'est un coup de téléphone
laconique de laëtitia qui leur met la
puce à l'oreille
elle parle d'une petite rechute qui se
pose une petite chimiothérapie
préventives et elle explique la réaction
des deux enfants ensuite lowrie david se
parlent s'inquiète il doit se passer
quelque chose de grave
et décide d'aller immédiatement ensemble
à los angeles mise au courant johnny
hallyday s'y oppose et appelle ses aînés
c'est trop compliqué venez chacun notre
tour
bernard motté je me tourne vers vous l'a
tué c'est vrai ou pas ça c'est vrai ça
n'est pas ça c'est vrai tout n'est pas
vrai dans le livre de léna lutaud qui
est une grand reporter au figaro
oui mais ça c'est vrai mais si je sais
pas de quoi vous avez parlé d'autres si
vous parlez des troisième enfant non
mais c'est vrai qu'il n'était pas en
quoi on n'était pas au courant ni donc
sa seigneurie ça c'est vrai vous vous
êtes choqués match ne nous reste qu il
ya plein de choses qui me choquent sur
l'avs sur la première info je commence à
rejoindre un peu philippe geluck pardon
je te faire des ennemis mais ça commence
à me choquer je commence à être choqué
d'apprendre que j'ai des bars est
partout partout partout qui avait
beaucoup d'argent mais qu'en attendant
il y avait 16 millions qui étaient dues
au fisc français
un appel de l'évasion fiscale et
philippe geluck je n'ai rien contre lui
mais la blague qu'il a fait c'est la bio
cible je ne dis pas le contraire
jusque là on découvre que encore
beaucoup de maisons etc en attendant
c'est de l'argent nous peignons d'argent
qui n'avait osé en français je suis pas
fiscaliste et sur cette info là bas on
découvre à nouveau si c'est vrai ce que
tu dis on découvre à nouveau
ben que laëtitia a dit pas dit la vérité
qu'elle a écarté les enfants de johnny
et qu'elle raconterai on est en train de
le salir
franchement on doit un million d'albums
ouais je pense qu'on doit tous se taire
et respecter le mec sa carrière avant si
la grèce est de l'argent bravo ça use et
démago et fier de rester jouer de notre
agence qui est révélé dans l'hymne et
l'incroyable raisons de la brouille
entre les deux clans toi soprin avant a
vendu 17 sera toi tu tu as connu johnny
n'ont jamais connu ce conte un peu david
et you c'est ça ouais mais moi je trouve
que tout ça c'est beaucoup dans
l'échangé de leurs familles cela ça
prend des ampleurs même je pense aussi
aux enfants
petit à petit c'est beaucoup là quand
même ça devient le mot sur ce qu il faut
calmer un peu de vieux jeux alors là il
faut il ya plein de livres il ya plein
de livres qui sortent ce qui est encore
seul hic est sorti ce sens tant aimé et
la journaliste l'ena le nom donc et une
journaliste au figaro très sérieux
l'étau exactement plutôt à donner la
raison de la rupture entre laura et
david et laeticia est l inverse de ce qu
on a vu jusque là la raison de la
rupture sera incroyable vous allez nous
dire si c'est vrai ou pas dans l'aube
salah parler d'une histoire qui date de
à l'époque johnny et laeticia envisager
d'adopter un troisième enfant un petit
garçon mais david et laura s'y sont
opposés
considérant cet agrandissement de la
famille comme une folie compte tenu de
l'état de santé de leur père pourtant
dans le livre on apprend que david et
laura qui est très content de l'adoption
de jade et joy
et selon elle c'est véritablement
le point de départ de cette histoire de
famille elle explique cette épreuve a
agi comme un révélateur
la famille recomposée de johnny alors
littéralement explosé et elle parle
également du jour en décembre 2009
johnny gravement hospitalisés et que
david découvre la croupe mans de pipoles
au chevet de son père voilà ça il n'a
pas du tout aimé pour la première fois
que s'est violemment disputé avec
laeticia et à chasser les amis de sa
belle-mère
voilà en fait david était mécontent des
fréquentations aussi de johnny voilà une
fois ses soucis ses soucis de santé
quasi terminée johnny son tour de maxime
nucci darolles poupaud et robin le
mesurier tous très proches de laëtitia
ils n'étaient pas jaloux david mais
avait un rapport quasi filial
il n'est chimay que des gens qui étaient
moins compétent que lui dans son domaine
et est au tour de johnny comme maxim
nucci et david trouvait complètement
dingue que son père se soit laissée
empapaouter par cette nouvelle bande qui
en plus commercialement ne lui a rien
apporté et ce serait même laetitia qui
s'opposaient à cette alliance artistique
c'est ce qu'elle nous dit dans le livre
vert marque de famille combien de
familles ce genre d'histoire mais c'est
sûr bah oui il y en a partout mais bon
c'est johnny hallyday la laisser comme
ça c'est pour ça que moi je trouve que
c'est malheureux et c'est sidérant parce
que l'album est très bon avec l'album
bernard est ce que c'est vrai tout ça
alors ça oui effectivement dhabi trouvé
que le nouvel entourage johnny n'était
pas celui qu'il fallait pas le plus
performant en revanche le troisième
enfant adopté ça c'est faux
tu vas jamais été question de ce à quoi
ils avaient déjà déjà il a été très
heureux de ses enfants était pas
question qu'ils adoptent qui que ce soit
d'autre
alors kévin vous avez des infos kévin
séraphin mais c'est juste que cette
espèce de télé-réalité géante qui est en
train de se construire autour de jeudi
l'idée commence à devenir très gênant
même façon qu'on atteint maintenant une
limite un peu gênant pour le public
aussi
ce que tu dis on salit aujourd'hui
l'image d'un mec a quand même deux
petites filles jade et joy qui sont la
mine dorian public serait pas parce que
il ya fait il a fait un million d'albums
et leur présence de règlements de
comptes entre familles interposée ou des
journalistes sont téléguidés par un clan
de journaliste elle est guidée par un
autre clan et un moment donné on sait
mais on n'a même plus envie de savoir en
fait c'est fou comme la ville a été ou
fait peur pj les journalistes font leur
boulot c'est moi je suis pas choqué
c'est johnny hallyday et pour répondre à
soprano on veut tout savoir sur la
notion johnny je suis désolé c'est pas
une famille comme les autres c'est
johnny qui je pense est calme toi je
sais pas michel cymes
[Rires]
dis moi en fait c'est juste par rapport
dans le fond au fait moi c'est dans le
fond c'est quand j'entends des histoires
j'entends des familles divorcées
si les mêmes histoires que les gens ils
sont non il ya plein d'histoires de
famille à des rebonds des adhérents 10
mans il ya des trucs à des gens ils sont
touchés par de nouveaux par des gestes
des non dits et c'est des histoires de
famille et là je pense qu'ils décédé
c'est vrai beaucoup aimé mais on ne
pense qu'à un moment il faut essayer de
ramener quelque chose d'un peu plus
positif parce que là il ya des gens
peut-être un jour à force de grossir
tout ça il ya déjà évolué sur sa tempe
pour cracher pas ce que vont se dire
avec la force de diviser de divers de
diviser ça va créer un truc
[Applaudissements]
pourquoi réinventer passé à choquer et
là parce que moi j'étais parti sur les
maisons parce que ça vous choque qu'il
ait des maisons cacher j'ai tant mieux
pour sa fête tranquillité risque achille
emana après montiel bernard montiel a
dit il à papé au fisc gt bank ag pas 10
r on a eu des révélations sur les
enfants que c'est des mensonges c'est un
chiffon son sang il faut pas l'acheter
donc du coup je suis revenue là elle
enquêté pendant des mois des
journalistes sérieux vous plairait
beaucoup moins chez choqué parce que
dans n'importe quelle émission n'importe
quelle interview bouquin on se sert de
johnny même une petite phrase pour dire
dans l'inconnu on était dans la boule en
même temps qu'il a acheté du pain tout
le monde se fait mousser là dessus il ya
un jeu d'enchères c'est super malsain
c'est à dire que en fait dans toute
cette histoire il ya qu une seule star
et puis allez paillade qui tombe et que
sort des seuils de dubaï est et c'est
moche alors où tout ça on est
aujourd'hui des relations mathieu
vouliez dire quelque chose peut-être
normalement non franchement croyez et de
son vivant c'est quand même très drôle
parce que de son vivant personne n'osait
trop l'attaqué mahé quand les gens se
retrouvent en face de moi ça m'arrive de
me retrouver en face de lui plusieurs
fois
vous étiez perdu dans son regard une rue
mais personne ne disait rien à ce paquet
nous pour aller lui taper dessus
je trouve ça un peu facile vous même et
vous j'ai pas entendu j'ai dit même
après vous bouffez pas alors ça change
pas
débutons public attendait syrie de la
10ème à millions d'euros demandés aux
beignets qu'est-ce que public en vie des
souris vient pour nous dire qu'ils
effectuent dans 18 mois les invités ça
va on est où les relations lance moment
non moi je crois aussi qu'il est
important de dire aux gens qui nous
regardent pas ce qu'il ya à force ils en
ont ras-le-bol ces histoires je me
réunir avec eux c'est que johnny restait
le plus grand je ne sais pas je suis pas
sûr que ça le touche à lui la preuve
c'est que les gens à acheter l'album
maintenant on révèle des choses parce
que laëtitia c'est un clan il ya david
et laura de l'autre côté les gens ont
envie de savoir ils ont toujours exposé
leur vie donc qu'ils aient envie de
savoir mais ça ne touche pas l'idole de
johnny johnny restera l'idole quand des
gens sont là aujourd'hui à besançon ou
qu'ils attendent le procès c'est très
difficile plus alors non il se marre à
ma très bien tout ce que je voulais
savoir merci on en reparlera bien et on
n'en peut plus voilà mais on est mais
c'est vrai que ça intéresse encore voilà
je vous dis